jada is ordering mother's day gifts
online
the shipping costs are based on the
dollar amount of the order
for orders less than twenty dollars
shipping costs four dollars for orders
twenty dollars or more shipping is seven
dollars
can the dollar amount of the order be
represented as a function of shipping
costs
so they're saying
can the dollar amount of the order so
can the amount
of order
be represented as a function
of shipping let me do that in that blue
color can be represented as a function
of
shipping shipping costs so if we have
shipping costs as an input will that map
to exactly for a given input will we get
exactly one output for the amount of
order in order for this to be
represented as a function
in order for this to be represented as a
function we have to input a
a shipping cost a shipping cost where we
where this relationship is defined we
need to input a shipping cost put it
into our relationship and get exactly
one dollar amount of the order in order
for this to be a function if we get
multiple
dollar amounts of the order then the
relationship it's well it's still a
relationship but it's not going to be a
function so let's think about it what
are the possible inputs here
well there's only two possible shipping
costs shipping costs are either going to
be four dollars or they're going to be
seven dollars so let's think about what
happens when we input four dollars in as
a shipping cost
so if we input four dollars into our
relationship so we input four dollars
into our little potential function box
so four dollars into it what is the
output what is going to be the amount of
the order
well if the shipping cost is four
dollars the amount of the order
the amount of the order could it just
has to be anything less than twenty
dollars so it could have been one dollar
it could have been a dollar fifty
it could have been
seven dollars it literally can take on
any value between up to twenty up to
twenty dollars so it could even be
1999. we could do a similar thing if we
inputted seven into this relationship if
seven was then i could put literally an
infinite number of numbers it could be a
million dollars so if i input seven
into this but this relationship that
we're trying to test whether it's a
function if seven is the shipping cost
then the order we just know is over
twenty dollars twenty dollars or more so
it could be twenty dollars it could be
eight hundred dollars
it could be it could be one million
dollars there's actually an infinite
number of values that it could take on
right over here so because for a valid
for a valid shipping cost i can for each
of these valid shipping costs i can each
i can get many many many potential
outputs i don't know which output it
necessarily will output to for if you if
someone tells you the shipping cost you
don't necessarily know
what the order size was this is not a
function you cannot represent the amount
of order as a function of the shipping
cost so no